at the end of the day I'm I'm an
optimist because I believed power of the
ideas of individual freedom democracy
deity markets but those are such
powerful ideas and they have worked so
well for so many people for so long that
I think those ideas will carry the day
because there's so much better idea than
the other ideas of you know nationalism
and socialism and fascism and
fundamentalism and the other the other
ideas that are just keep people in
misery so I think that the war of ideas
will be one eventually and I hope they
will be one not only in the rest of the
world but also back here in the West
that we will return to you know the our
founding values and respect other
people's liberties just as much as we
value our own liberties
you know technology is something that is
very seductive to a lot of people day
they too quickly jump to the conclusion
that you know all we have all this great
technology now so the answer to all the
world's problems of war and poverty and
disease and everything is just
technological just apply the right you
know technology version 7.0 and you fix
problems well that's not how problems
actually get solved by technology the
technology only works when it's embedded
in the actions of guests again free
individuals operating in free markets
here are the incentives to you know find
the right technology to solve the
problem at hand or democratically
accountable governments that have the
incentive to find the right technology
to solve the problem at hand technology
is not a disembodied forest that will
solve problems and owns it requires
human beings to solve problems so I'm
not I don't buy into this kind of you
know the sort of Thomas Friedman
worldview that you know we have this
great technology and all you have to do
is just sort of plug into the internet
and globalization will take over and
solve all the world's problems you know
I I don't think things work that way I
think they require lots and lots of
supporting human institutions that
respect individual rights free markets
democracy these things unfortunately
build up more slowly than technological
quick fixes they are only evolved over a
couple of centuries in the West and
they're evolving you know slowly and the
rest of the world